Over the past few months, I've noticed a
number of comments all expressing
something similar. With that being the
idea that tutors, cards that search a
player's library, are in some way out of
place within the landscape of casual
EDH, or at least within the landscape of
lower power levels. In particular, I've
encountered this when I discuss cards
that are quite powerful compared to
everything else in a deck. I've at times
brought up the scenario of a powerful
card being an obvious tutoring target,
sometimes in a way I find uninteresting.
And a common response I get is, "Well,
why are you playing a tutor then? That's
your problem right there." On an
objective level, this person isn't
wrong. The tutor is part of the
immediate problem here. And I wouldn't
be having an obvious card to grab if I
wasn't grabbing anything in the first
place. However, there are some deeper
disagreements taking place here.
Disagreements about the foundations of
EDH and what it stands for. So in this
video I want to explore those
disagreements and to discuss the nature
of variance, variation and luck and what
role these things should play within a
game of EDH. Different players will have
different ideas of how much of these
things should be present in a game of
commander. And these opinions are often
phrased as proclamations about what
falls within the spirit of the format.
So what does this phrase mean? Well, the
best way to dig into this is to look at
the way EDH differs from other magic
formats. Decks are 99 or 98 cards,
significantly more than the 60 seen in
traditional constructed formats and the
40 scene in limited decks. EDH also has
a one copy limit on cards within decks
as compared to the four card limit for
60 card formats. And together, these
restrictions make it so that for any
given card, a deck will often be around
a sixth as likely to draw it in an EDH
deck as compared to a 60card deck. This
fact alone has led many people to make
the observation that EDH is a higher
variance format than other formats. For
the non-mathy folks, the word variance
sounds a lot like the word variation.
And that's actually not an incorrect way
to think about some of the implications
of these numerical realities. Because
there are more different cards, each
with a lower average chance to get
drawn, there will be more variation in
the cards that get played within a game
and between different games. As a result
of this, decks will generally feel new
and fresh for longer, and play patterns
within a game are often less
predictable. All of this is great, as
far as I'm concerned. Recently, I've had
a strong interest in decks containing
lots of sub themes that can combine in
all sorts of ways. The challenge of
optimizing and tuning a deck like this
to actually play well is a blast, and
it's a blast that could only exist in a
format like EDH. Within this sort of
synergy machine deck, tutors can be a
helpful tool to help an otherwise
disjointed deck actually play nicely.
But excluding tutors can likewise be a
fun challenge that forces an even
greater degree of deck cohesion. Some
people choose to play the EDH format at
a power level that demands a greater
degree of consistency in cards
available, but a high degree of card and
play variation is absolutely an
enjoyable thing to cultivate where
possible. All of this sounds good and
agreeable. But something you may have
noticed is that this pedestrian
interpretation of the phrase variance
has strayed pretty far from the sort of
scenario I mentioned at the start of
this video. I'm not talking about
whether you'd use a tutor to find any
old card. No, I'm talking about
situations when a player uses a tutor to
find some piece of degenerate nonsense,
a card that will dramatically impact how
powerfully their deck plays. To tackle
that question, we need to talk about
variance in the mathematical sense. And
we need to talk about it in terms of how
it applies to power level. The power
level variance of a deck basically
refers to how widely a deck's power
level differs moment to moment and game
to game. This is difficult to track
exactly, and obviously in a multiplayer
format like Commander, a deck's
momentto- moment power level won't
always directly translate into wins or
losses, but most people are going to
have an intuitive idea of what I'm
talking about. When a deck is
progressing effectively toward goals
that will lead to winning a game, it's
having a more powerful game. If a deck
has access to a powerful card like Soul
Ring or Skull Clamp, it's going to be
having a better time on average than if
it had access to Mindstone or Rogu's
Gloves. If you take nothing else away
from this video, understand that a game
with a lot of card variation is
different from a game with a lot of
power level variants. You can have one
without the other, and a defense of one
of these things isn't necessarily a
defense of the other. When it's already
a foregone conclusion that a powerful
card is going to exist in your deck, the
question of whether to run tutors for it
then becomes the question of whether
you'd prefer to have that powerful card
frequently or infrequently. On a
probabilistic level, the deck that runs
the tutors will be more powerful than
the deck that does not. Let's say we're
using a I don't know seven point power
scale. That's a fun number. If drawing
into a particular power card naturally
leads to a six power game, tutoring it
leads to a five power game due to the
extra cost and/or inconvenience of the
tutor and not having the card leads to a
three power game, the expected power of
the deck that runs tutors will be higher
than the deck that does not. If you're
figuring out what power level games to
play the deck in, and you're a certified
math dork running the odds, you could
say, "Well, the expected power level of
the tutor version is 4.1, and the
expected power level of the non-tutor
version is 3.3." And then this could
determine the decks you choose to play
this deck against. Problem is, both of
these decks are going to have that power
level six game 10% of the time. It's
just that one set of opponents is going
to be a bit better prepared for that
situation than the others. This abstract
approach demonstrates the core of the
issue with decks having a higher degree
of power level variance. But that
abstractness makes it a bit less helpful
in understanding realworld cards because
different powerful cards accomplish very
different tasks. So let's talk about
some real world magic cards. For
starters, let's talk about the
quintessential card in this sort of
discussion, Soul Ring. I've been
jokingly calling this card my Wizards of
the Coast mandated dose of variance
whenever I draw it for the past several
months, and it truly is a massive
injection of variance. It's one of the
most powerful cards in the game,
indisputably the most powerful mana rock
in the format after the banning of Manac
Crypt, and it's been printed in every
precon out there. So, this should be an
example of the great woes inflicted by
power level variants, right? Well, not
exactly. And this is where things get a
bit more nuanced. Soulbring is powerful,
but its power is somewhat less felt than
a lot of other cards. And this is for a
few reasons. First of all, it only
provides mana. If you don't have good
things to do with this mana, it's not
going to be all that powerful. Decks
still have commanders, a bonus card they
can cast at any time, so it's rarely
useless, but it might only be modestly
powerful in some circumstances.
Secondly, it's a lowcost card. One mana
for a rock that taps for two colorless
mana is insanely powerful. Yes, but that
power falls off rapidly, and drawing it
past turn five or so might not even be
that desirable. Thirdly, it's a card
that is typically far back in the
progression of winning a game. If we
think about a deck as having a pipeline
that runs from the start of the game to
the hypothetical point at which it wins,
Soul Ring falls right near the beginning
of that pipeline. Since commander is a
multiplayer format, this will often give
opponents a lot of time to collaborate
in slowing down the soul rigging player,
negating some of the power level bump of
the card. Now, does all of this mean
that soul ring's power is something that
never feels bad? Absolutely not. The
most problematic instances of Soul Ring
tend to be where there was already a bit
of power level imbalance between decks,
and especially if some of the weaker
players kept poor hands or had unlucky
openings. Saring can be an equalizing
tool for the weakest players, but it can
also be drawn by the person piloting the
most powerful deck, boosting what might
have been a workable game into an
outright pub stomp. Calls to ban Soul
Ring, or now to put it on the game
changers list, exist for a reason. The
card is far from the bane of the
format's existence, but it's also not a
perfectly unproatic tool, and that makes
it a good place to start. Following the
pipeline model, what falls on the
opposite end of the line? Well, it's
ways to win the game. Typically, ones
that are near instantaneous, such as
combos or combo adjacent cards. These
tend to lead to the most jarring
instances of power level variants
because the table doesn't have much time
to react. You go from playing the game
to having it end without enough time for
any sort of table coordinated response.
I'll elaborate more on why this sort of
thing constitutes a problem in a bit,
but naturally when there is a problem, a
card that wins the game immediately will
be the problemist. Incidentally, this
pipeline model also makes it clear that
removal can be a tool for power level
variance mitigation on the scale of a
game. Between soul ring and cards that
outright win the game will be a bunch of
cards somewhere in the realm of what
might be considered an engine. The
engines that only provide card advantage
will typically be closer to soul ring in
terms of their position on the pipeline.
Card advantage is quite good, yes, but
it can take a little while to fully pay
off into a win since mana will still be
a limitation. The one ring can feel
quite powerful, but the table should
still have a decent bit of time to work
together and stop a one- ringing player
if they start to get out of hand. The
engines that are further down the
pipeline are the ones that grant mana in
some form as well. Think something like
Bolas's Citadel or Arcane Bombardment.
When one of these hits the board, the
table might be a single turn cycle away
from fully losing control of the game,
or even less in some cases. So, this is
the four-point model I'd like to go
with. You've got your early game stuff
that is more of a temporary boost than
anything. You've got your midame engines
that can start to push out of control if
given time. You've got your late game
engines that signal an imminent threat
to your opponents. And you've got your
truly game-ending cards at the very end
here. Obviously, these are categories
I've defined with specific sorts of
cards, but it's possible to categorize
basically every proactive magic card
into one of these based on how
imminently they threaten opponents in a
game where they might be considered
powerful. And that's the key here. The
utility of these categories is in
analyzing a card that already seems like
a possible power level outlier of sorts.
Power level variance will be felt more
sharply the further along this pipeline
a card is due to the social nature of
the EDH format. As I mentioned earlier,
a soul ring is quite possible to play
around and typically only an outofc
control power spike in very specific
scenarios when there were other factors
lining up at the same time. By contrast,
there are all sorts of scenarios where a
crater hoof behemoth or a misix mastery
might feel like a shocking or
unsatisfying turn of events. And
fundamentally, that's my broader problem
with power level variants as well. The
wider a deck's play patterns span in
their power, the more difficult it is to
put together good matchups and the less
satisfying games will be. Let's think
about a midpower raccoon deck. We're
doing a bit of ramping, playing some
raccoons, and then maybe throwing down
some cool topend spells once we've built
up our mana. But now, let's say the deck
contains a Godtom combo in it that can
instantly win the game if the Godo is
drawn and the deck has enough mana. Or
heck, maybe even just a few especially
strong top- end creatures. What power
level of game do you play this deck in?
You could play it alongside other
flavorful midpower decks, but you might
randomly smash them with an out-of
character power play. Alternatively, you
could play with other decks that have
some higher caliber plays, but then you
might just get destroyed when you only
draw into a bunch of Fair Magic Raccoon
friends. When decks have such a high
degree of power level variance, it's
hard to find a fair game to play them
in. And if you choose your game based on
the fair 80% of the time game plan, the
other people at the table may be in for
a rude awakening when you draw the 20%.
In addition, even if you find a table
that seems suitable enough for the deck,
this degree of randomness is destructive
to a lot of the things that make
Commander a great format to me. One of
the most important elements of the
format is its multiplayer feature.
You're playing alongside three other
people and games often require
strategizing and performing threat
analysis, figuring out the best way to
navigate the landscape in front of you.
The issue with decks that have a high
power level variance then is that they
make threat assessment almost
impossible. There is no landscape if
you're playing against a bunch of decks
that do a mixture of power plays and
durling around with vague synergies
accomplishing very little. You could
target down the person who currently has
the most threatening thing on board.
Maybe this is where some people like to
stop with their threat assessment, but
you can't ask yourself, what will these
decks be doing later? Do I have any sort
of clock I need to worry about from this
player? Like some sort of combo game
plan they're assembling, or will this
other player get ahead with overwhelming
value if they aren't pressured? Now,
this information is unknowable if the
power of a deck's game plan is
determined by raw chance. And the end
result is that commander turns into a
luck game. It's seeing who draws the
powerful stuff and who puts it together
at the right time and who happens to
have the exact answer available at the
exact right time. To some players, this
is likely fine, good even. Commander is
a very diverse format with lots of
people looking for lots of different
things out of it. You're allowed to
enjoy the more luck-based version of
Magic where concepts like strategy and
threat assessment are reduced down to a
shadow of their usual selves, but you
should at least be able to understand
why if other people don't want to play a
commander game somewhere along the lines
of wizard flavored yatsi or dragon
themed bingo. Obviously, I have strong
personal feelings about what degree of
power level variance I find fun in a
game. But rather than spending too much
time berating you with that, I think
it's worth asking another question. Why
do so many people end up with decks that
might be considered higher variants?
Some of it is likely intentional, but a
lot of it comes down to the nature of
the EDH format and the culture that has
developed around it. EDH is naturally a
format where plays need to be larger in
scale and this is for two simple
reasons. Life totals are doubled and
there are two extra opponents.
Naturally, then it's common to see a lot
more cards that are synergistic. They
rely on other cards for some of their
power. This is not in and of itself a
bad thing and a well- thoughtout synergy
package can make for a fantastic
backbone of a deck. However, when
packages are narrower and when they
don't tie together as well and when
decks go overboard on certain types of
payoff, problems can arise. It's pretty
common to see decks with lots of cards
that are only good when the deck is in a
specific situation, like having an ideal
board state, having specific types of
support, being ahead in some way, and so
on. This is common to see because humans
are bad at thinking about chance. Let's
say you have a little micro package with
six enabler cards and four payoff cards
for a particular thing. What are the
odds that these actually show up
together in the top 15 cards of your
library? The answer is probably lower
than you think. There's a 64% chance
you'll have one of the enablers, a 49%
chance you'll have one of the payoffs,
and a 30% chance you'll have both. This
means you'll have a large amount of time
where one or the other of these is a
dead card unless they're well integrated
into the rest of your deck. And that's
not even considering whether or not you
have the mana to cast these things. Take
that into account and you're probably
south of 25% of the time. Long story
short, humans are exceptionally bad at
thinking about the probability of
multiple things lining up just right at
the same time. For a little analogy,
this is why sports betting apps make a
killing on parlays, bets on multiple
specific things within a game happening.
People make these bets because the
payouts are higher, but in reality, the
probability of multiple things happening
at the same time is typically low enough
that these bets end up having massive
margins for the apps, even with the
higher payout. Taking things back to
deck building, this fact of probability
means that if you run a bunch of cards
that are mainly only good alongside
other cards, or mainly only good when
you're already in a decent situation,
you're going to end up with a high
variance deck. And not in a way that I'd
find fun personally. You'll have some
games where cards show up together at
just the right time and you're able to
take over the game and other games where
things don't come together right and you
end up puttering around on the sidelines
while more consistent decks are able to
actually play the game. And this is to
say nothing of the relationship these
decks have with removal. A deck that
hinges on being ahead on having a
specific situation be the case, even
simply on having its commander stick
around long term. Well, that's a deck
that's going to have a rough time
against an opponent who has the
interaction to keep it in check. If an
opponent has seen your deck performing
well, and if performing well means
absolutely going ham on the board,
they're going to try and slow you down.
If your deck also putters around doing
nothing when it has a key piece removed,
well, you've just set yourself up for a
one-two punch of not having fun. You
might also call this sort of deck a
feast or famine deck. When it's able to
do its thing, it dominates whatever game
it's in. But when certain key pieces are
kept off the board, either by bad luck
or opposing interaction, the rest of the
decks cards aren't able to do much of
anything. Another thing that contributes
to a high degree of power level variance
within EDH, is that people feel more
willing to put especially powerful cards
in decks when those cards work with
their commander in some way. You'll
certainly occasionally see people who
will toss powerful infinite combos like
Helio Ballista or Dualcaster Twinflame
in any old deck they can cram it into,
but it's much more common to see people
throw in cards that combo with their
commander. In my video on the subject of
turning commanders into a combo piece, I
bring up that large percentages of both
Zaxara players and Tivot players play
one card infinite combos with their
respective commanders. This isn't great
when it occurs in a deck that is mostly
winning in decidedly mid-power fair
magic sorts of ways, such as sacrificing
clues with a disciple of vault in play
or swinging in with a handful of
normalsized hydras. This is true for the
reason I mentioned earlier, turning
games into a strategy to void swingy
luckfest, but also because it can impact
the threat assessment of your opponents,
causing you to attract extra hate even
when you're playing with the decidedly
fair magic half of your deck. So, why do
people choose to make this sort of deck
building choice? On some level, the
existence of these power cards probably
feels like a gift. The sort of play that
would feel out of place in a deck is
rendered acceptable to people due to it
tying in with their commander or a major
theme in their deck. It is, as I would
jokingly say about Soul Ring, a
prescribed dose of variance that has
been handed down by the abstract godlike
figure that is Wizards of the Coast. The
same goes for cards that are more in the
realm of engines. I gave a couple more
minor examples of this in a recent
video. Wastist knot in a discard deck
and monument to endurance in a cycling
deck, but there are numerous examples of
commanders or archetypes with one
specific midgame card that goes
absolutely crazy. Skull Clamp with
tokens, Thrming Stone in a Shadowborn
Apostle deck, Colossus Hammer in an
Arden deck, and so on. However, I want
to focus on one in particular as an
illustrative example. Kark's thumb in a
Yustri deck. Yusfree is a commander that
flips up to five coins when he attacks.
Most people choose five. And his
controller then draws a card for each
heads and takes two damage for each
tails. If five heads are hit, you get a
temporary omniscience. Spells are free
to cast until end of turn. On its face,
this is a spicy commander. If we do the
math, this is basically a creature with
two and a half double damage faxian
arena stapled to it and which also gives
a roughly 3% chance of an omniscience
turn. What happens to these numbers when
a Kirk's thumb is played? A card run in
91% of use redex? Well, the impact of
improving the coin flipping odds is
pretty dramatic. With five coins flipped
per turn, average cards drawn per turn
goes up from 2.5 to 3.75. Average damage
taken goes down from 5 to 2.5. And this
means that the average damage per card
gets cut down by a full 2/3. Even more
dramatically, the odds of an omniscience
turn are almost eight-fold improved. Now
sitting at just below a 24% chance, and
that's an omniscience on a turn where
five extra cards were drawn, it's not
hard to imagine situations where the
game is won either right then and there
or rapidly thereafter, even reasonably
early in the game. I don't think you
need me to tell you that this card
constitutes an almost absurd degree of
power enhancement for a use deck when
played. So, is this a reasonable variant
spike? Is it good for a deck commander
to normally be a potent yet painful draw
engine and in a much smaller number of
cases become a much more powerful draw
engine without the risk and with a one
quarter chance each turn of offering a
quite possibly game-winning benefit? I
don't necessarily want to answer that
question for you. In part because it's
more complicated than something like an
infinite combo and also in part because
you is a commander that already selects
for players who are looking for a
somewhat luck based experience. So, I'm
probably not going to be convincing that
person that this is any sort of negative
thing, even if I wanted to stake out
that position. I'm merely bringing
attention to this as an example of EDH
culture in a nutshell. The fact that a
full 91% of players are running Kirk's
thumb demonstrates the universality of
this sort of good cards are a gift
mentality, even in a casual format. It's
also at this point that I want to turn
things back around to the question of
tutors. Here's a question. Is it better
if a usri player runs tutors to find the
krak's thumb? Or is it better if they
allow lady luck to run her course and
bring them the thumb when she deems it
appropriate? I think a lot of people are
going to naturally default to the no
tutors option there. But why is that? If
you're going to be playing powerful
stuff, isn't it better to have it more
consistently and also give your
opponents the chance to strategize, to
consider their options, to weigh the
risks of different plays? Is it better
that they play against a janky coin
flipping deck that occasionally throws
on the gas randomly and then 24% of the
time has that gas turned into rocket
fuel? You can feel however you like
about those questions and I think it's
entirely reasonable to have some mixed
feelings about this sort of thing.
However, this example does start to
clarify the impact of tutors on power
level variance, particularly in a deck
containing more powerful cards. If
you're playing a deck with a handful of
power cards amidst a number of worse
cards, running tutors to improve your
chances of drawing said power cards will
lead to less swinginess since you have
access to the power card with some
degree of consistency rather than only
in a handful of games. However, this
usage of tutors is naturally sacrificing
deck variation. You're going to be
making more similar plays every game.
This can still be cool if you're running
a sort of secret commander deck where
you're able to build off the
consistently tutored card in a variety
of different ways as you might do with a
commander, but this is likely a minority
of cases. This brings me to a second and
somewhat stranger usage of tutors.
Tutors can help you in the process of
identifying cards that might be out of
place in terms of their power level
variance. To build off a real world
example, I recently heard a content
creator discuss an experience they had
that caused them to cut the tutors from
one of their decks. They had tutors in
their Vela the Nightclad deck, and they
found that all too often they would
tutor for right of replication, a card
that can copy Vela five times and deal
30 damage to each opponent. This is a
one card combo that will instantly win
the game in many situations, if a very
mana inensive one. The Vela player found
this a bit boring after a while and the
response to this was to cut the tutors.
But when I heard this, my first thought
was, "Wow, think about the gift your
tutors just gave you." Like, these
tutors have identified a card that is
exceptional enough to be the correct
tutoring choice most of the time and
have also given you the chance to decide
that that exceptionality feels a bit off
and in the process have given you the
chance to indulge a bit and play the
card a few final times. Put in more
general terms, tutors let you see what
cards you're gravitating toward, and
they also give you extra opportunities
to decide how you feel about a card. If
you're tutoring for a card a lot, you
can ask yourself, "Have I been enjoying
having this card more often?" If the
answer is yes, great. All is well. If
the answer is no, well, that gives you
the opportunity to make some choices. It
might be that the card is out of place
in your deck, but it also might be that
the card represents a game plan that was
fun for a bit, but that you've already
gotten your full amount of enjoyment out
of for the moment. In either case, you
now have the opportunity to try
something new instead of that card. In
my most tutor intensive deck, my Sharoom
slide deck, I'm always performing
exactly this sort of analysis. There's
obviously the part of the deck
pertaining to the flicker enchantments,
and I never get tired of those since
they're what the deck is built around.
But my artifact fetching wizards give me
the opportunity to see what I tutor for
and which of those things feel
satisfying when played a lot. The only
cards I find myself tutoring for first
every time are Soul Ring and Fluctuator.
And both of these are fine since soul
ring is just mana advantage and
fluctuator is a core card I can play
around. On the other end of things,
Portal to Forexia is a powerful card I
was worried I'd be tutoring for too
often with my treasure mage, but that
really hasn't been the case. There are
just so many useful top-end artifacts in
the deck between windcons, removal of
various types, life gain, and other
utility cards. In fact, portal hasn't
even been my most common target for
treasure mage. That honor goes to Angel
of the Ruins, though even then, I'd say
that's only my pick about 30 to 40% of
the time. Part of the joy of a toolbox
deck is the action of figuring out the
right tool for the job. And balancing
tutor targets so that they all get the
chance to be the correct pick across
different situations is a great way to
optimize the fun of a deck like this.
This act also naturally smooths out the
power level of different cards, making
for a more consistent experience with my
draws in addition to my tutoring.
Ultimately, whether or not you add
tutors to a deck is a personal decision,
and I'm not really trying to sway you
one way or the other on that. I
presented these four quadrants in my
last video to illustrate four different
philosophies on whether to tutor for a
powerful card. And returning to them now
can illustrate how deck building
decisions play out. In a deck with a
handful of more powerful cards,
including tutors will likely reduce the
power level variance of the deck and
lead to a smoother game-to-ame
experience. But it will also likely have
the side effect of reducing card and
play variation, making the deck more sy.
This puts a deck in the first quadrant.
Not including tutors will do the
opposite. Decks will have a greater
variety of plays game to game, but they
may have sudden power level spikes here
or there when a powerful card is drawn.
This puts a deck in the third quadrant
here. The fourth quadrant is one where
most cards that might spike a deck's
power level are weeded out, but tutors
are still included. This is a generally
low power level variance style of deck,
and the play variance of this sort of
deck really depends on its pilot and how
it's built. Some people might value
getting different cards each time and
combining them in different and creative
ways, whereas others might look for a
more consistent play pattern with less
variety. A final fifth category might be
a deck that combines neither any major
power outliers nor any tutors. And this
sort of deck would likely be both high
variation and low power level variants.
Ultimately, the biggest thing I want to
get across here is that these two things
are separate knobs. The tutor conflict
within the casual EDH community isn't a
battle between people who want different
things every game and people who want
the same experience every game. Nor is
it a fight between skill havvers and
luck enjoyers, nor a duel between good
players and bad players, nor a skirmish
between pub stompers and fun havers.
There will be elements from some of
these dialectical clashes present, but
also a lot of other things, including
some I mentioned in my last video.
However you choose to build your decks,
the best I can hope for is that the
framework I've laid out over the past
half hour might be helpful in the goal
of building something fun. Thanks for
watching, and I have an announcement. It
is a deck building challenge based on a
Tumblr post my brother sent me a while
back. The rules are simple. Submit a
deck with no ease in any of the card
names. Submissions can be made on my
Discord server until this coming
Thursday, end of the day. You should
also include a approximately 100word
story or poem, also containing no ease.
I'll be highlighting a handful of decks
in my next video. With that out of the
way, thanks to Architect for supporting
the channel. Architect is my deck
building site of choice, and it has lots
of great tools for analyzing your deck
and seeing the likelihood of drawing
cards from different categories, which
can help with managing varants. I'd also
like to thank my patrons for their
support. I produce one bonus video every
month only for patrons, and I'll be
including a preview of this month's
bonus video right now. As an experienced
Magic player, I find Commander Mulligan
rules very forgiving. I find that I
rarely get mana screwed in a deck where
I am building it in a way where I'm, you
know, focused
on not getting mana screwed. Um, I I
will build decks where I am leveraging
mulligans hard and in those cases you
will have kind of the off games where
some issues happen. But I can build a
deck where I'm never going to get mana
screwed most of the time. Like there
will obviously be like the one in a 100
games where I have to mulligan down to
four, but uh you know I think for the
most part it's possible to build
manabases where
you aren't going to have problems. You
know free mulligans followed by a London
mulligan is just pretty forgiving. Um
now if you're a newer player, I'm also
not judging that at all. Um, but I find,
you know, this sort of comment very
funny when this person clearly knows
that uh them running a low land count
and them not using normal mulligan
rules, these things are clearly tied
together and yet they still write the
comment. I don't know. I find it funny.